gare à celui ou celle qui s'en prendre à
l'ex miss france bailly malama chaves et
surtout à son physique
l'influent seul c'est aussi devoir faire
face au jugement et à la bêtise des
certaines personnes la jeune femme
encore une fois été victime de critiques
sur ses rondeurs alors qu'elle se prêter
au jeu des questions-réponses sur
instagram un internaute lui a posé cette
fâcheuse question paix en simple une
question très maladroite à laquelle
veille malama répondu sans détour et
dans un ton très crue tu ne devrais pas
demander à une femme s'est elle est
enceinte
parce que nous on ne demandera jamais si
tu as un enfant du matin comprenez par
enfant du matin mieux readme sperme
expression entendue au maroc comme l'a
précisé l'ex miss france avec un petit
astérix une nouvelle expression qui
vient compléter son champ lexical et qui
apprendra à ses fans à tourner sept fois
leur langue dans leur bouche avant de
parler
le prochain
l'enfant du matin je la garde celle là
et moi c'est très bon alors est ce que
toi quand tu fais des tic toc ou des
live parfois tu as des connards avant
achat rachat qui sont désobligeants avec
toi avec ton physique
ouais ça oui ça fait partie du jeu on a
toujours qu'il voulait faire en tant qu
ils vont commenter un truc à avoir pour
décembre mais ouais toujours mais est-ce
que tu ne réponds août justement tu tues
tu ignores tu dises est décédé c'est des
connards par des pins quand j'allais
chose à répondre dépouille cgt compte
actuellement photo ni moins d'accord
avec elle on donnait quand c'est trop
c'est trop faut faire mais il faut faire
fermer la bouche des gens plutôt quel
exemple de répondre un peu violemment et
j'ai vraiment à l'opposé quand même de
sa chérie justement il faut les ignorer
faut laisser puis au bout d'un moment ça
s'est mise à l'eau de la réponse de
weimar a émis le mois moi c'est un génie
à chaque fois je la trouve très drôle
dans ses réactions et je trouve qu'elle
a totalement raison de faire ça c'est
très compliqué ce qu'elle se prend à
chaque fois dans la tête et le fait
d'afficher les gens ça va peut-être
empêché certains de se dire bah voila je
vais peut-être pas aller la défonce et
parce que de toute façon pas m'afficher
après et donc dû là je vais prendre tout
le monde et à la raison en fait à un
moment donné ça ou d'avoir honte d'avoir
honte d'avoir ce genre de réflexion
d'avoir honte de poser ce genre de
questions à la à la mord moi le noeud et
c'est pas à nous de nous cacher ou
d'ignorer parce que sinon c'est trop
facile parce que mine de sables est
quand même quoi qu'il arrive tu
prendrais dans les pays où figurent donc
ya pas de raison jean pascal
ben moi je trouve que justement les gens
ils se cachent derrière des pseudos
souvent en plus c'est faux pas toujours
12 ouais mais c'est des trucs existent
pas qui se cache dans l'ordinateur donc
je pense même pas que ça les blesse quoi
ils font ça justement peut-être pour la
personne que la personne s'énerve mois
j'ignorais totalement quand j'aurai même
pas répondu parce que ça met la personne
en avant on laisse passer la question et
on passe à autre chose
moi j'aurais fait comme ça quoi je suis
pris le commandement alors moi j'ai
juste une petite question parce que
qu'est-ce qui vous dit que la question
était mal intentionnés à ce que moi qui
fait des paris
une fois de me tromper et de dire à
quelqu'un qu'elle était enceinte et
j'étais vraiment j'ai pas voulu humilier
parce que d'abord c'est pas humiliant
degré quelqu'un forcément mais j'aime
pas et là peut-être que c'est un jeune
qui est derrière son téléphone qui est
fan de cette miss et qui lui a dit sa
maman
du coup de lui répondre comme ça je suis
un peu entre les deux vous vous passez
par les processus
moi je suis d'accord avec toi et déjà
quand on accepte ce jeu sur instagram on
est exposé à avoir des questions sur son
intimité ne chante pas répondre à ce
genre de questions faut pas y participer
et ensuite la question si elle est
enceinte ça peut être une question de
bienveillante thé ensemble c'est pas
forcément oui bien qu'elle ait pas rond
c'est là la réponse est très vulgaire je
trouve que la miss s'est du coup les
jeunes
franchement faut savoir que les
personnes qui critiquent elles sont très
mal heureusement donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut les ignorer parce qu'en
général quand on est heureux on va pas
les critiques de certaines routes et moi
les plombs et très heureux du soutien au
crédit qui s'est passé je ne dis pas que
les plains je dis juste qu'il ya un
moment donné il faut vraiment moi je ne
les ai pas ignorer dans le passé et ça
n'apporterait rien il faut vraiment
ignorer ce genre de personne et c'est
très méchant comme ceux de dire à une
femme qu'à l'est en asie à l'image des
impôts
ah oui à l'époque oui quand j'ai compris
nrj 12 c'est eh oui je sais vous m'aimez
bien j'essaie oui et du coup on est loin
du coup c'est vrai que c'est très
méchant parce que une femme qui est très
mal dans sa peau quand on lui dit
qu'elle est enceinte
ça peut très très mal le prendre comme
d'autres femmes savent pas du tout les
toucher